what is up reject nation we're gonna
watch brooklyn nine
nine today season one episode eleven
christmas
is here early and it's christmas in july
it's
perfect i know yeah something something
could have
really not been july guys thank you so
much for being here brooklyn nine-nine
is a blast
currently only episode eight is blocked
so we got rid of the seven clay but now
only eight is blocked in the u.s and
canada if you guys would go ahead hit
that like button it helps us out of the
algorithm
if you would like subscribe and click
that notification bell full length watch
along where you sync up with the time
code
or over at our patreon cover a bunch of
shows we're over there the same tier you
get the option for reaction highlights
and watch along
included really really do appreciate
everyone who's been here brooklyn
nine-nine is just an absolute joy of a
time
um so thank you and pratham jindal thank
you for any of these highlights for us
bud i don't know how
you feel about the show are you enjoying
it it doesn't matter edit
edit away it doesn't matter if you enjoy
anything in this
life just make videos for thumb
[Music]
all right you take the skinny one on the
right i'll take the big one on the left
all right fine come here
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's right boom just kick sand in the
testicles
very nice oh
merry christmas it's okay
those kids know santa doesn't care
you're learning this on the guitar
yeah do do do do
and the horn part i learned the hard
part of the guitar
let me guess your egg sandwich fell on
the floor and they gave it to you for
free
no can you do that why doesn't everyone
just drop their sandwiches on
gift is for captain holt it's one of six
presents i got him representing the six
lessons that he's taught me excuse me
everyone detectives sometimes feel the
urge to buy their captain's holiday
presents
please refrain from doing so under no
circumstances
do i want a present
captain holt has received a number of
death threats ow
well it may be a hoax but protocol
dictates that captain holt have a
security detail with him
at all times he's chosen you for that
detail
you'll be entirely in control of his
movements amazing he will not leave your
sight
[Laughter]
basically you'll be completely in charge
oh well it sounds really tough but of
course i accept and i will be willing to
put my life at risk for this man
to have to follow all of my orders thank
you this is the best christmas ever god
bless us everyone
hey my flight is at eight tonight it's
domestic i think i'll be safe if i get
to the airport
five hours early why are you going on a
singles cruise i thought you're into
rosa
well i am but i've begun to feel like
there's a slight
chance rosa may not love me back hey how
about we grab some dinner tonight
just you and me that's nice i don't like
you as a person but i'm just not
interested in you
romantically coolio oh
listen to me the healthy thing for you
to do is move
on so we both decided the healthy thing
for me to do is to just
move on i'm impressed charles that's
very mature we're gonna wear santa hats
and big sweaters and take a picture of
us all in the lineup
i'm sorry santiago but i don't have time
for that my psych evaluation is today
they're gonna decide if i'm ready to
make it back on the streets why do you
care what they think
psychologists are just people who
weren't smart enough to be psychics
[Laughter]
you can sit there all day affirmative
stone eagle
that's the secret service code name i
gave you whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa where
are you going cold mountain i changed
your code name
sergeant jeffords thank you for coming
in today we are here to assess your
readiness for active duty
and if all goes well i will stamp this
release form
you can go back in the field well i
think i'm ready oh no i am no longer
fixating on my fears
good but for today let's fixate on those
fears
let's begin by talking about your baby
girls and your wife
and uh what would happen to them if you
died
in the line of duty wow
[Laughter]
where do you think you're going i'm
going home to work in peace do you know
why i chose you
to be my security escort because i'm a
modern-day sherlock holmes
no i chose you because the threat is not
real
i thought you'd have no problem breaking
the rules and letting me get my work
done
well you thought wrong you can't go home
it's protocol
but if you really want to get out of
here you can come to my mom's she lives
nearby
or i can lock you up in the holding cell
with an armed escort totally your call
fine we will go to your mother's house i
guess i am curious to see where
this all started
so this is my mom's place you can just
throw your jacket in the closet
that's a bathroom water closet my mom's
british
are there no photographs of you no
holiday decorations
nothing but this isn't your mom's
apartment it's a safe house song
jordan from this point forward we're on
lockdown
fine but before we go into lockdown too
late you're on it i'd like to text my
husband and tell him i'll be coming home
late tonight
all right but for security reasons i get
to craft the message
oh you will not craft the message give
me my phone
fine all right so here's all the
pictures of rosa that we have which one
should we use
the bottom bottom right bottom right
well what about if we
flip those lips ugh
oh no to get a picture of rosa smiling
hold card has to be perfect
guys i can make rosa smile just keep
your cameras ready
making coffee can you make another cup
for seeing your tickle in this new heavy
amigos
what the hell headstock
next time i break it off
oh do you think that was gonna go
fun safe house is a safe safe house
my sir
a safe house watching safe house is a
safe safe house house
i've already seen the film i enjoyed it
wow i would not have guessed that
who knows we're here get behind me
no jesus no suggest that you put me in
another room before you open the door
but
you've cuffed us together i ordered you
to be quiet oh he didn't text his
husband did he
three seconds jake it's me charles from
work
okay let's switch gears what do you
think of when i say the word
bottle liquor store hold up
how about grass marijuana
gun die what are you doing
you gonna stamp my form no i just didn't
want the ink to dry out
boyle what are you doing here i thought
you had to catch a flight i do my flight
is in six hours
the captain texted me to come so i'm
here what you texted boyle when you told
me you were texting your husband
as the person who's completely in charge
here i am very disappointed in you
i'm changing your code name to bad boy
imagine what it's like to be
disappointed in someone under your
command
okay i see what you're doing tushy
[Laughter]
please don't involve me in this i'm just
here to uncut the captain and take him
to his old precinct
what oh wait a minute you weren't going
home at all
you were going to investigate the threat
because it's not a hoax it's real
wrong it's not real you're lying you
have a tell
when you lie the corner of your mouth
moves and it just moves wrong it's not
real
fine though i'm not sure who's behind it
love that i want to solve it on my own
boyle uncuff me don't do it charles i'll
take you on that trip to the botanical
gardens we've always talked about
uh it's just like christmas at my
parents house what do they have separate
dining rooms
oh jeez
i love you both so much
who wants to watch safe house
how many people have you put away that
might want you dead i've arrested over
600 people
boyle will you please read the
transcripts of the threats he's received
you will drown in your own blood the
next one is
i'm gonna send you off the deep end
drowning and deep end
almost sounds like he's talking about a
swimming pool it's hames
ah-ha who's hames colin haynes the
freestyle killer he took out an entire
4x100 meter oh
god marco
no you say polo
[Laughter]
looks like you needed our help after all
together we figured out it was hames and
together we're gonna take him down
because together we can do anything here
we go
i'm finding haynes alone
russell guess what i accidentally opened
your mail and here's what it says dear
miss diaz you just won no i'm reading
the letter and you're taking the picture
you're trying to get me to smile for
your dumb picture but you messed up
[Laughter]
what's going on with you why are you
being so weird about this i don't need
your help
no one should get hurt because of a dumb
mistake i made as a brash young
detective
hey james you're gonna spend the rest of
your life in a little cement room
doing nothing and while you're in there
i'm gonna go for a swim
and after that swim i might take another
swim and you'll just be sitting here
on your metal toilet thinking of
knees
when i get out of lockup i'm gonna hunt
you down and
kill you yeah wow
that's why i decided to change
everything about my life but if you
would truly change you'd be saying a
bunch of boring responsible stuff like
don't be stupid use the detective squad
you're part of a team i smell like
sandalwood
all right let's go updates warrant for
the phone trace came through we got
hames's number
and the last coordinates from its gps
the rail yards
all right we got him everyone suit up
sorry you missed your flight oh i have a
backup flight in four hours
[Laughter]
of course you do of course you do boil
you're prepared
we got his number now call his phone
it's ringing
that is haym's phone i repeat everyone
converge on that ringtone
he's heading north on track 17.
[Music]
go go go
ray hull hello hales thought about you
every day i was in jail just like you
said
i thought about pointing the gun at you
and pulling the trigger kind of like
[Laughter]
[Music]
nice terry's back nice work jefferson
nice work peralta captain you're doing
it
you're emoting
let's boil it down what no not
on christmas die egg
oh
he loves rosa sarge i'm so glad that
shrink cleared you
captain holt needs your help his life is
in danger oh sarge i
do not think that you're ready
i'm ready huh this is exactly the kind
of thing i was hoping to avoid
captain this is our job any one of us
would have taken that bullet
you were right we couldn't have caught
him without the team
it appears the student has become the
teacher and the teacher
has to become that's enough okay
team pop and lock here we go come on
still
we saved your life oh my god
it's happening yeah we did it
it just goes right back to
oh
what you did was amazing yeah boyle that
was some superman stuff
yeah you did the nine nine proud no ifs
ands or butts
sorry it's just right there even though
i got shot in the butt
sorry i'd rather be here spending
christmas with all of you
than on some stupid singles cruz and i
mean that the bottom of my butt
i'm sorry wow shut up jake will's a hero
christmas card complete
he got shot in the butt
that's the magic of christmas i've hurt
my butt before
i've been shot in the butt before yours
is a lie
minus truth yeah i know
i just want to take a sledgehammer in my
ass
why can't i have a cool butt trauma like
you i don't know
but man when i was single that story got
me laid
yeah you want to see the wound come back
to my place i'll show it to you
guys like oh he's dangerous yeah man
what's up
especially big crater shaped ones in
non-visible places oh what a sweet
episode what a sweet christmas episode
delight you know it must take boyle
getting shot in the ass in order for him
to finally start winning some of rose's
affection
yeah i mean that makes a lot of sense
from a character's standpoint
that's actually the last thing i
expected from this episode today was
oh there's gonna be a turn of events
where rosa's gonna start showing some
some some of the infection in the ass
and the smiles with the teeth and all
that
i love how that's the thing that gets
her to finally smile oh absolutely
that's
like so adorable it was one of those
things where especially yeah
towards the end when things start
resolving you're like ah
you guys thought this through
and i think they've talked about it a
little bit before with how
parts of peralta kind of remind holt of
a younger version of himself i don't
know how direct they've been about that
but this episode clearly showed that
oh yeah and i love getting that contrast
of like okay part of the reason he is
why he is
because he used to really not be that
guy
yeah and that's why i want to turn his
life around and then having to pay for
the consequences of that level of
behavior
that was cool of be literally being able
to flip it around
where you know is still like uh an
annoying
uh like he's not annoying to me he's
hilarious but he's
you know in the context of the show this
uh annoying pompous
arrogant cop who is loving too much
having too much fun with taking control
of holt's current circumstance but yet
still
making the right calls and the right
choices and bringing them to like the
gag you're like other houses keep
getting more and more handcuffed
yeah yeah yeah one and the way it comes
back around of him calling him out like
it was one of those
episodes that had that extra little bit
of
you know like character motivated oomph
so that you know like although
yeah it's like when they're handcuffing
each other all together and like just
the more and more it keeps growing it's
it has the wacky hijinks and whatnot and
then i love that they were able to
actually
yeah turn it into something that
eventually encapsulates
every part of the episode you know
because it even brings terry back in and
i love that because it's like
around the time like right when he burst
back and i was like oh that's right we
haven't seen him in a while and he's
mostly just been in this one little plot
thread
yeah they know how to get you to root
for everyone because like with terry's
situation you're like there's no way in
hell he's gonna get approved now
yeah but he just takes it into his own
hand he just needs the right motivation
he just needs the right reasoning and
when the time calls for it they show you
through visually how he is fine
yeah yeah just when yeah the right
circumstance arises
don't even have time to get lost in the
fear it just matters what he's focused
on
most of our anxieties and fears are stem
from where our focus is and where our
attention is usually it's a
a matter of of perspective so
once his focus shifts to saving bam
he's a hero and that was cool to get
that moment like that was a great
that was a really rewarding scene for
him to just go in there and tackle the
bad guy like you don't
you really don't see that moment coming
at all
it's funny it's rewarding because you've
been rooting for terry
uh yeah this was there's another another
really good episode
it's a lot of heart with that friendship
continuing and you're rooting for these
characters
and it's funny how these two holiday
episodes have managed to
really bring the spirit of what those uh
holidays
ultimately represent yeah getting shot
in the ass getting shot in the ass
and uh and yeah and uh you know finding
the person who's headed out to kill you
for
decades now now i gotta find something
to criticize because you know
he can't just he can't just do one of
these criticizing
praise and clap at everything gee but
claps
but cheat claps dude clap that ass i
thought the hitchcock and scully jokes
fell flat i thought the thermos bit was
very funny just because
how not urgent that is but yeah i mean
like the whole tickling thing i was like
that's not gonna work and i know exactly
where that joke is headed but yeah i
mean like even still
i i get a kick out of them it just ruins
the whole episode
this ruins everything it's like there's
no christmas now
christmas is cancelled clearly hated it
yeah someone right now is typing
why do you need to find something to
criticize
because we don't know what else to do
because all we're going to do is just
sort of be on repeat about what's good
about this
guys take a drink because it's another
great episode of the show it's
a really fun episode with all great
character beats to keep the post
discussion exciting for myself
i just gotta point out a nitpick in
order to
feel like i'm doing something a little
different during this talking
i'm pick good a plus nitpick
yeah because uh this was a it was pretty
great
mm-hmm and hey i mean like you know man
i think she's i've really turned around
on her oh yeah absolutely
yeah no i mean everybody like you know
it's like she's the last piece of the
puzzle but it seems like they've really
found the right pitch because yeah
especially thinking back on these past
handful of episodes in a row
she's each time had at least a moment
that really cracked me up
very true yeah good good run of it have
we been halloween thanksgiving christmas
all in one yeah how do they air these
episodes i don't know
like is every season is there just gonna
be like a a quarter of the seasons just
all holidays like what they do like
all right we're airing this in october
and then we'll order this next one some
point in november
december and then next week we're on the
new year's episode
and we'll wait a couple months and we'll
wear valentine's day
how does this work all right guys so
thank you so much for being here
brooklyn nine-nine is uh
it's a delight it's a delight can't wait
to meet kevin
i know i haven't met him yet right kevin
if that is his real name or just a
nickname cute knick-knack i i can see
that being a joke
you guys leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button last but not least let's do a
scoobs the steve my
friend don't be messing around in
brooklyn near the
nine-nine because we know you we know
your criminal activities and you're
gonna get caught and you're gonna get
locked up in the
slammer scoobs
but don't worry we're not we're cool
we're not gonna snitch on you as long as
you stay pledged
keep on doing your graffiti arts on the
down low
you know keep on showing up to the place
that you work at
helping people with their lives
and all that looking after the
vulnerable of our society
let's see who you really are scuba steve
you're
you're like the spirit of christmas man
and i hope that you're feeling good
today i hope that this july
you're feeling festive and we'll we'll
be talking soon scuba steve in fact
if you ever do commit a crime we'll just
use your pledge money